en tout cas selon le procureur de la cpi
armelle des crimes de guerre serait et
bien commis sur le territoire ukrainien
la cpi qui a ouvert une enquête après le
feu vert des 39 états qui en font partie
le recueil des preuves va donc pouvoir
commencer il sera bien sûr l'on est
particulièrement difficile parlons de
cette guerre dans la guerre celle des
images des chiffres de l'information
d'une manière plus large pour la
première fois la russie reconnaît des
pertes
498 soldats tués au combat le président
ukrainien parle-lui de 9000 russes morts
au combat c'est le grand écart des
informations sh&e invérifiable à cette
heure quoi qu'il en soit pour le
secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken c'est déjà trop
fidji
new bike and run
armelle on rappelle les chiffres 480 18
9 milles d'un autre côté on a l'habitude
de ces chiffres par exemple lors des
manifestations à entre la police et les
manifestants la bataille de
l'information je le disais bat son plein
oui elle est cruciale en plus parce
qu'en fonction du nombre de morts que
vous avez dans les armées vous
connaissez le spectre en fait des
batailles qui sont en train de se jouer
sur le terrain et si vous regardez est
ce que vous savez où sont les batailles
aujourd'hui on les voit quasiment pas on
voit qu'on a des images dans les villes
donc on pourra la voir à kiev on peut en
avoir à kharkiv ont pu en avoir
évidemment un peu sur les zones russes
qui sont prisme est très très peu et
l'intérieur du pays très l'intérieur du
pays on sait absolument pas ce qui se
passe on a aujourd'hui des grandes
plaines parce qu'effectivement ces
grandes plaines agraire qui sont là il
ya quelques valais mais pour les russes
pour leur char ça se franchit très
facilement donc est ce qu'il ya des
batailles en ce moment avec l'armée
ukrainienne on n'en sait rien et ce qui
est important de souligner parce qu'on
est une chaîne équilibré c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de chiffres du côté russe mais il
n'y en a pas non plus du côté ukrainien
la l'ukraine ne communique pas non plus
sur ces armes et elle pourrait
communiquer là dessus on n'en sait rien
donc c'est vrai qu' il faut faire
attention parce que peut-être qu'après
on se rendra compte qu'il ya des grandes
batailles ou qu'il ya eu effectivement
des exactions des massacres à certains
endroits d'un côté de l'autre toute
l'histoire des balkans nous a raconté sa
et donc après effectivement il ya la
justice internationale qui s'en saisit
mais si on prend aujourd'hui ce qui est
en train de se passer dans la zone
j'allais dire tenus par les russes on
n'a quasiment aucune image qui est sorti
merci armés